so one of my favorite examples is using
scandal right we open up scandal hearing
from two other people talk about olivia
pope
one of them is the trusted source
how does a writer introduce a
protagonist in a way that makes
the viewer or the reader want to follow
that character yeah good question i
actually did an entire workshop on how
do i and i call them how the f right all
of my workshops are in the what the f
workshop series so this particular
workshop was how the f do i introduce my
protagonist right and there are a
million ways to do it but what we're
looking for is what information are you
going to give me about them in their
normal life that makes me like them or
relate to them i don't have to do both
it's 20 21 so i don't have to like the
character they can be totally unlikable
but something about them has to be
i have to be able to relate to in order
to care enough and invest in them on
this journey so
um i use the word social proof and
basically what that means is prove to me
going back to the evidence right prove
to me who they are on the page whether
that means we're receiving information
from someone else
or we're watching them do the thing
because just like regular human beings
you can only
take what they say about themselves with
a grain of salt
right so i can sit here and go i'm an
expert i'm an expert i'm an expert but
unless you actually hear me giving my
expertise on something or you hear from
someone else who you trust who says
shannon is an expert
then you're probably gonna say i'm not
one so on the page you have to then show
us
that your characters are whoever it is
you want us to believe that they are so
one of my favorite examples is using
scandal right we open up scandal hearing
from two other people talk about olivia
pope
one of them is the trusted source
the other one is the fish out of water
who
already has some kind of admiration for
olivia pope right so as we're hearing
them talk about olivia they're putting
her on this pedestal and now we are
therefore intrigued to go well who's
this olivia i want to know her she seems
cool and then in the next scene olivia
now has to live up to the thing that we
just heard so now you have to show us
in action they could have gone to the
next scene and olivia was just sitting
there having a meeting talking you know
on the phone to herself but instead they
put her in a situation to show her
social proof in doing her job and so
hearing from those other people first
and then seeing her actually do the
thing is what made us
want to journey with olivia pope so the
same is true for your characters there
is no particular kind of formula but
what i will say is you got about five to
seven minutes
to get me engaged with your protagonist
um some stories won't start with the
protagonist which is fine but that means
if it didn't start with the protagonist
and then we meet them you have less time
to get me to like or relate to them
because i'm already x amount of minutes
into your film so for example i'm
teaching from armageddon right now right
we don't meet harry stamper i think a
snapper until like page 10 which means
we're we've been here for 10 minutes
already
because we got our exciting incident on
page two
so that means the urgency is already
there they're already making up a plan
by the time we meet harry i only get
like three pages to really understand
who he is
and jump into action with him to decide
to invest in him so now you have even
less time because i'm already 10 minutes
into it but either way whatever it is i
see them doing first so you can't be um
generic about that like oftentimes i
will read a screenplay and it's just oh
such and such woman who's beautiful is
cooking breakfast
and it just seems like she's cooking
breakfast because she needs busy work in
the kitchen not because cooking
breakfast teaches us anything about her
right is she cooking breakfast because
she's a stay-at-home mom and she's in
her pajamas and she has to get up early
even though she's going to be at home
but because she's got to get husband out
she's got to get kids out and she's
getting it done or is she career woman
who's cooking breakfast so she doesn't
really have much time because she's on
the phone at the same time she's just
trying to get something in and it's a
smoothie and she's running out or is
this saturday the only day that she gets
to you know relax and she's making
brunch because her girlfriends are
coming over like what does it mean and
what am i learning about this person as
their cooking eggs because if not they
could be doing something else you know
what i mean so every single piece of
information that i get in those first
five to seven minutes are going to help
me know who they are and that's prime
real estate and a lot of people
pass right through that prime real
estate by doing the uncle such and such
thing
talking about all this other stuff that
does not matter meanwhile all i got
about my protagonist was beautiful and
cooking eggs
why am i invested in her
you know what how is that interesting
why would any actor who reads it say
i gotta play her right so you're trying
to give me some information that's going
to give me a reason to invest in the
rest of their journey and you only get a
very short amount of time
okay so if something doesn't happen
within a five to seven minute minute
mark to show me why i should care about
the scene
so then if we have this woman
cooking um these eggs and then maybe
there's a knock at the door and it's um
you know some door-to-door uh salesman
so we think
and it turns out it's really a private
investigator and they're
saying you know i have something for you
and her life is about to change in that
moment
and she finds out that her life and what
she thought it was wasn't really that
but we don't know in that moment so
everything seems calm and wonderful and
you know she's beautiful and she has
this nice kitchen but then the knock at
the door is going to be what's going to
upset the apple cart yes but i want to
make sure that we separate the two
things right that that upset of the
apple cart can happen 15 pages in it can
happen 17 pages in
everything that i'm getting up until
that upset
is what's making me invest in her
why do i care that her life is going to
change if i haven't learned anything
about her life other than the fact that
she cooks eggs
right
what information are you going to give
me does she have a child that she's
caring for
that they have a really great
relationship with does she have a
husband that she has a bad relationship
with and she's just today's the day
they're supposed to go to therap therapy
and she just really wants it to go well
and then this thing comes in and
interrupts that right so what
information am i getting about this
person's everyday life that's already
worth investing in so that when the
upset comes i too can be upset
like no she really needs to go to
therapy today she doesn't have time to
deal with this door-to-door guy you know
or no her sleeping child is in the other
room and she tried so hard to have
children and she finally has one and
then here comes this person and are they
posing a threat to the child that's in
the other room right and again none of
this has anything to do with eggs so the
question is did we need to open with her
cooking eggs like what does that mean
for her as a character or maybe it means
everything because she's really a chef
in another life but because she decided
to be a stay-at-home mom you know blah
blah blah or maybe it means i'm always
going to make sure my husband's eggs are
great
we argue every morning but these eggs
matter today because we have therapy
later and i want him to be happy when he
gets to therapy right now all of that
stuff is making me invest in her so when
the person comes and knocks on the door
i understand no no no we don't need this
interruption like we don't need this to
happen
you